Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, this is going
to be my Doctor Who Episode 10 video.
Even though next week is the beginning of
a two part finale.
The forest story felt like it wasn’t directly
connected to that.
We did see Missy again so I’ll try to explain
what I think she was doing.
And just in case I don’t have time to do
a separate video for it I’ll address the
footage in the finale trailer.
Heads up, because I missed last week’s Q&A
video I’m doing a double giveaway for this
week.
All you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment.
I’ll explain after we get through all the
WTF.
Careful for spoilers if you’re not caught
up, here we go Top 5 Moments
Number 5 - Little Red Riding Hood Finds the
Big Bad Wolf
I guess I shouldn’t be surprised about the
use of Fairy Tales in Doctor Who.
I remember when they made the transition from
Matt Smith to Capaldi a lot of the bigger
blogs were saying this was an end to the Fairy
Tale era.
But Moffat is really the one who writes the
Fairy Tales, so as long as he’s still running
the show, there will always be elements of
that.
I don’t mind it too much, We got Red Riding
Hood, Hansel and Gretel, the Jungle Book isn’t
so much of a fairy tale but when we saw the
Tiger I thought of Shere Khan.
Ruyard Kipling
was a British Author.
In all the preview clips they called it a
magical story.
I did find it kind of hard to explain the
sister appearing at the end and Maebh’s
ability to influence reality.
I kind of had to suspend the rational part
of my brain that searches for explanations.
It’s possible the creatures could be involved
in the finale, the big cutaway at the end
didn’t feel like closure.
Number 4 - The Earth Protects Itself
The creatures magiced up the trees as a way
to defend against the solar flare.
The Doctor made it sound like they were protecting
humans but really I think they were just protecting
the earth itself.
This was a very Earth Day type story, stop
cutting down the trees.
They’re trying to help you.
It would have been totally appropriate to
air this during Earth Week but that’s during
a different part of the year.
Missy was surprised by they outcome, so I
think she might have just been a passive observer
in this episode.
I’ll talk more about her in a sec.
There’s been so many moments in series 8
where the Doctor has been confronted with
the subject of his longevity.
Like almost dying permanently last week, the
joke on the moon about not being sure if he
wouldn’t go on regenerating forever when
the astronaut almost shot him.
This week the creatures explained that he
was just blip in their timeline.
One of the best lines of the episode was “We
are the life that prevails” - that was actually
in one of the first series 8 trailers.
But I think it was the good Dalek that spoke
the line that time.
This theme about life prevailing is going
to come back in the finale.
So just make a mental note about that.
Number 3 - Clara and Danny Pink
Danny apparently still has no idea Clara has
kept up with the Doctor as if nothing has
changed.
Given everything we saw in the finale trailer
and how positive he came off in this episode
it totally seems like he’s going to be one
of the tragic heroes of series 8.
Like a Rory type figure and even though there
was the big Clara WTF moment in the trailer,
she did seem like there was a part of her
that bought his line about seeing the things
right in front of you and all the wonders
down here.
Another one of my favorite lines was when
the little girl explained they were yelling
at each other because they loved each other.
There are so many Doctor Who jokes about people
being Scottish and complaining, being angry
but caring deeply.
It all just reminds me of Karen Gillan and
Catherine Tate.
I don’t know if there’s any truth to the
rumors Jenna Coleman is leaving the series,
but you could see all these teasers about
Danny Pink trying to win her over as foreshadowing
for Clara not traveling with the Doctor any
more and just living a normal life.
Even in the face of the reveal in the trailer.
Clara never having existed, it’s possible
Moffat could give them a version of a happy
ending.
Like Amy and Rory got a twisted kind of happy
They were together at least to the end of
their lives.
Even if they were trapped by the weeping angels.
Number 2 - Class Assignment, Save the Planet
All I could think about when all the children
climbed on board the TARDIS was this was a
Children In Need Special, like they were doing
something that under no circumstances would
happen in normal Doctor Who stories.
And the wiser children explaining things reminded
me of wesley crusher being the little kid
on the enterprise surrounded by mostly very
serious adults.
I could see where a lot of people would be
put off by the use of children in the episode,
but given the fairy tale aspect of the story,
Maebh and the Coal Hill field trip I think
it worked.
The Doctor didn’t seek the children out,
Maebh sought him out.
She even knocked on the TARDIS door.
It’s one of those rare moments when you
know someone is special.
Like when The Doctor explained GUS from Orient
Express had phoned the TARDIS.
There are just some things that no one is
supposed to be able to do.
So when someone new is able to track down
The Doctor it’s really interesting.
Missy even had that line.
“This is a surprise, I like Suprises”
and my Number 1 WTF Moment - The Finale Trailer
Since I might not have time to get an extra
video out just for the trailer we have to
talk about it.
First off, the Cybermen.
Worst kept secret this year.
The BBC even posted pictures of them to their
official page, they brought Cybermen with
them on the World Tour.
I saw they cybermen spoilers when they were
filming many many months ago.
I know a lot of you saw them too.
It was really hard to omit them and the details
about Missy from my series 8 videos.
Now we can finally talk about almost everything.
There are still a few spoilers that weren’t
in that trailer.
So please use spoiler tags for cyber conversion
related things.
All those cybermen have to come from somewhere.
Second, Clara Owald never existed.
Very shocking claim, so it’s possible that
Clara is like a tesselecta or advanced cyberman
that Missy is operating.
Or she’s like Mr Clever, an advanced version
of the Cyber Controller that doesn’t look
like a cyberman.
They’ve had human form Daleks, of course
they can do the same thing with Cybermen if
they wanted.
Either way, Missy is controlling Clara.
If missy really was sitting inside a Cybermen,
with the little eye behind her here there’s
still a lot to explain.
But she’s walking around with The Doctor
here.
So there’s still a big question about the
nethersphere.
They kept talking about Invasion and things
living in-between universes.
Like the creatures in this episode.
They exist in between the spaces in reality.
So The Doctor saying “The Invasion is over”
it’s already won seems kind of prophetic.
It makes it seem like missy is going to spring
cybermen everywhere instantaneously and it’s
going to involve some alternate dimension
jumping.
Like the nethersphere is a pocket universe
type alternate reality like the forest creatures
live in.
Lots of theories to make but Clara Betrayal,
Missy Invasion and what does it all have to
do with The Doctor being Missy’s boyfriend.
Let me know what your favorite moment was
and for the Q&A, I will do
a Q&A for this.
Just remember, Clara is seen emerging from
one of these Cyberman chambers, in this scene
she’s got a cyberman pointing a gun at her
and UNIT is a big part
of
the story.
So I think it will be
a
lot
more complicated that Clara just being
a
Missy Puppet.